hey
i don't know where i should go
why where should we go man
yo hold up hey hey there's no wherever i
do go there's no one be ready
260 and on
[Laughter]
he does not look like he's 260 pounds
something he needed to get out there
after the report from the new york daily
news that the jets have concerns about
le'veon bell because of rumors whatever
that he had ballooned to 260 during the
season in which he didn't play football
he looks like he's in pretty good shape
and he isn't he's going to be in very
good financial shape as of march the
13th because somebody is going to pay
him a ton of money to come in and
transform the running game and part of
the passing game because he is a very
dangerous weapon out of the backfield
catching passes at one point his demands
from the steelers were driven by his
belief that he should be paid like a
number one running back and a number two
receiver that's the kind of impact he
was having in the pittsburgh steelers
passing game now where will he go and he
deserves to have some fun with this
after sitting out the entire year as
part of this business strategy aimed at
getting life-changing money
multi-generational
life-changing money so good for him and
it's good to see him enjoying himself
and it'll be good to see him back in the
nfl now somebody tweeted recently if the
eagles get le'veon i will lose my bleep
and le'veon retweeted that
with hmm
and uh one of those emojis like
that like the emoji is thinking very
hard about what may happen so and and
the eagles are a team i did weekly spots
during the season last year on wip in
philadelphia and every week up until the
week 10 window came and went and le'veon
bell was shut down for the year there
was an angle about le'veon bell to the
eagles up until the trade deadline is
there a way that le'veon bell ends up
with the eagles and think about what a
guy like le'veon bell could do for the
eagles and they've got carson wentz for
one more year
maybe two more years although the second
year is going to be
the fifth year option which will be
north of 20 million but until they they
pay carson wentz a huge contract they
could afford to to dump a lot of money
into le'veon bell's pockets
so the eagles are one of the teams you
would have to at least put on the
fringes of being in play
they didn't have jay ajayi for much of
last year he tore an acl from time to
time it felt like the running game was
kind of lost in the shuffle and we know
how important the running game is to
that equals offense so that is a team
that that maybe possibly should be
considered the jets are a team that
that we've been talking about really
from the get-go and i've i've believed
from the moment it looked like le'veon
bell was setting this up to get the free
agency the jets would be the team that
would pay le'veon bell for reasons
related to football and for reasons
unrelated to football because they're
trying to compete with the patriots
trying to compete with the giants
they're trying to sell tickets they're
trying to sell psls still and they have
a few years left with sam darnold under
a relatively small contract in
comparison to what he eventually will
have when he gets his second deal so pay
le'veon bell a bunch of money over the
next few years helps sam donald grow
into the quarterback he he needs to be
for the jets to be as good as they can
be so that makes a ton of sense plenty
of other eagles players noticed what
le'veon bell had to say
chris long had a gif of a smiling dwight
schrute and malcolm jenkins
had a picture with the words come
quickly on it so the eagles would like
to have le'veon bell the jets i think
would like to have le'veon bell there
aren't a ton of teams
that really need a workhorse running
back
uh but there are enough and all it takes
is two last year at the end of the day
it was the jets and the vikings that
were pursuing kirk cousins that was it
and that was enough to get cousins 28
million a year fully guaranteed for
three years and here's how this will
play out we'll be in india this week and
and
the scouting combine becomes tampering
central in the nfl because
there will be communications that
naturally occur between agents and teams
about
players currently on the team
represented by that agent and oh by the
way that agent has other clients with
other teams who are due to become free
agents and they'll talk about them as
well and and they do it face to face so
there isn't a paper trail there isn't uh
you know cell phone trail there's
there's nothing that can be used to
prove that these conversations happen
and they will happen it i i want to say
it's the best kept secret it's a worst
kept secret it's not even a secret
anymore it happens
the agents will go to indianapolis
because they have a meeting there in
connection with the nfl players
association and the agents will meet
with the teams and some agents will meet
with every team and when adisa bakari
who represents le'veon bell leaves
indianapolis he will know the teams that
intend to eventually make an offer to
secure le'veon bell now it used to be
that the numbers would be put out there
one thing that this 48-hour legal
tampering window that we see right
before the start of free agency where
offers can be made one thing that has
done it's gotten teams to be a little
more discreet a little more vague about
what they'll offer they defer that until
later in the process for now though bell
will know the universe of teams he'll
know if the jets are in he'll know if
the eagles are in he'll know if the
cults are in although no one thinks the
colts are going to spend the money
necessary to get him and by the way they
have marlon mack under contract for a
couple more years at a very favorable
rate any team that's got a young running
back under a rookie contract you don't
want le'veon bell even if you're using
that young guy as your workhorse you
don't want le'veon bell to replace him
because you're going to be spending a
ton of money on le'veon bell and any
team that likes to go with two or three
running backs that team's not going to
want le'veon bell you know it and
something that we'll do for pft we'll go
through the standings we'll go through
the 32 teams and identify any team that
potentially could want them and more
importantly the teams that definitely
wouldn't the cowboys aren't going to
want him the vikings aren't going to
want him any team with a young workhorse
running back is not going to want
le'veon bell but again all it takes is
two
and i have a feeling it'll be more than
two
it may be
four or five by the time it's all said
and done the raiders could jump into
this who knows but le'veon bell is going
to get the contract that he couldn't get
in pittsburgh and and there will be
people who say well this contract
doesn't make up for the 14.5 million
that you lost last year but if it's got
significant guaranteed money if it's
better than the deal
that the steelers offered le'veon bell
in 2017 and 2018. remember the steelers
won't guarantee money beyond the first
year of the contract they won't do it
other teams will this is what le'veon
bell has been waiting for and one of the
big reasons he's not going to be back in
pittsburgh because the steelers will not
structure contracts the way that most if
not all other teams well i think the
the bears may be the only other team
that is careful about guaranteeing money
beyond that first year other teams will
do it someone will do it for le'veon
bell and le'veon bell is going to make a
ton of money on or before officially on
march 13 but he'll know on or before
march 13 where that money's coming from
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports